it's one of those dishes that everyone
thinks is scary because it sounds fancy
and that you can't make it because it's
too hard but it's actually so simple you
can do it by yourself i believe in you
hey i'm matthew and i'm going to teach
you how to make coco van coco van
literally just means rooster with wine
an old chicken cooked in wine so let's
start with our chicken coco van is one
of those classic recipes that if you get
the foundations right you're going to
end up with a stellar product every time
really give it a nice judge so you have
the salt and pepper all over that
chicken then we have something that's
called a bouquet garni which essentially
just means bundle of garden herbs it's
just so you can put it all in one bundle
into your dish and be able to take it
out later in here i have thyme bay leaf
and parsley and i'm just going to plop
that in and then it's time for the good
stuff you want to use a good burgundy
wine for coco van that's the most
classic and i know that's like a lot of
wine but it's just a part of having this
dish enjoy it embrace it it's going to
be so delicious
so we're going to go in with the bacon
bring the heat up slowly so you render
all the fat from the bacon to cook the
rest of your chicken and your vegetables
in
you hear that can you hear that
and scoop out the cooked bacon and put
it to the side so that it can drain take
the chicken out of the marinade and put
it onto some paper towels so that it all
soaks out and then take even more paper
towel and pat it on top to dry it you
really don't want your chicken to still
have a ton of moisture because then if
you put it in the pan it's just gonna
steam and boil instead of getting that
nice brown crust you want okay and now
it's time to go in for that flip
oh perfect
oh yeah what we're trying to go for is
that my yard reaction that really deep
brown fried skin that's gonna give us a
ton of flavor for the chicken you don't
want to skip this step at all it's
important but it's not hard don't worry
about it you can do it it's easy we're
gonna add the vegetables carrot and then
onion
lots of mushrooms and then a wee bit of
garlic
i'm gonna start stirring it so my
veggies are looking really great they're
softened they're brown so now i'm going
to add in the tomato paste you want to
cook the tomato paste until it turns a
little bit darker and you can really
smell it sprinkle in the flour because
once you start to like boil any kind of
liquid all the starches in the flour
will gelatinize and thicken any kind of
sauce you have so now it's time to add
the brandy there's going to be some
brown bits on the bottom which is called
the bond and i want to scrape it off and
reincorporate it back into the sauce
this is called deglazing the pan which
is vital to making that classic
flavor for coco van add in the rest of
the reserved marinade make sure those
herbs go in there as well and now you're
going to bring this to a boil and let it
reduce by half add the chicken back into
the sauce so it can continue to cook
then i'm going to sprinkle on the bacon
and then put the lid on and let it cook
on a low simmer and if you're worried
about adding the marinade that was
touching the raw chicken earlier don't
worry about it this is going to like
essentially boil for 30 minutes to an
hour so there's not gonna be any raw
chicken juices anymore okay now let's
cook those fresh vegetables to put on
top of the cocoa van
then we're gonna put in the peeled
pearled onions and some sugar onions and
mushrooms can be a little bit bitter or
pungent and some sugar really helps
contrast that you kind of want them just
to be lightly golden and steamed so that
way they are bright and vibrant to put
with your kind of deep rich stew you see
coco van is not that hard it's one of
those dishes that everyone thinks is
scary because it sounds fancy but it's
actually really easy to make this dish
is so good okay challenge yourself do it
for yourself i know you can come on this
is what life is about good food
coco van is so delicious and i know
you're gonna love it
is there any other recipes that you want
us to teach you how to cook if so please
let me know i want to share my love and
my passion and my knowledge with you
oh it smells really good you smell it
i love chicken
guys
guys come and try this